I think we're going
just a few notes on these speakers and
the commentators as you want to say that
this is a collaboration between two
programs
Sasha's first book of shadows into the
streets
we'll have two responses tonight first
Dane sax is a freedom operator works out
of Chicago it's an educator and works on
challenging and is also president and
artistic director of product this is an
organization that creates new models of
cultural participation and experience
so the ethicists of this whole series is
own practice art practice as a way of
addressing serious contemporary issues
social awareness social imagination
stimulate massive number of issues today
our second respondent will be sido
Google tsubame and dumb Andrew Bryan
sheriff in parts and education at the
Harvard grad school of education means
the faculty director of the Arts in
education program in a former director
of problem zero his current research was
talking with artists who teach a study
working artists ideas and insights into
the nature of artistic development and
learning so
[Applause]
I'm really really excited to introduce
John not gonna read or just share a
story of our past collaboration to come
to know each other so we actually met
first in 2008 we were both in this video
which was a citizen journalism video and
documentary collaborative that gathers
together in twin cities in 2008 to
provide grassroots coverage of the
Republican National Convention
it was meeting in 2008 at a time the RNC
in cities imagined it was that it was
heavily militarized there were thousands
of riot police there's lots of tear gas
looking through the streets of st. Paul
in cities there was intensive it was
turned out later that there
process where the FBI had it will create
some of the key organizing groups that
were involved in putting together
protests against Republican National
Convention and some of the FBI agents
had come up with a plan to violently
attack police intervention Center in
Maine and of course come up with this
idea and found materials and basically
the new plans make all this happen so we
were there we arrived we both have been
should have asked the numbers as a
previous work we had done in media arts
in community journalism media network
media centers Network radical grassroots
storytellers and journalists that
emerged during the late 1990s prior to
the existence of and so my first
experience with Marissa were kind of in
this intensive situation of heavy police
repression and we remember we farmers
were small teams of videographers and
fathers to go out and document what was
happening Nicole nervously mentoring and
is also to provide footage that can be
used as legal evidence with legal teams
that we're going to get people out of
the bogus charges that we knew the
police were throwing people for
peacefully protested and so our members
were going out into the streets and we
were taking turns shooting put in
and swapping out mini DV tapes you
remember those I remember so we had to
hire many DZ tapes
there's a whole system for returning in
takes because we knew that these were
targeting sort of social movement
videographers and so we've had a drop
drop points all around the protest zone
where you have hidden tapes
so we were working together to try to
document this up at coverage not get
clubbed or asked too much and tell that
story
partly to establish where is the street
cred as her background and what was
necessary but also because what I do
remember from this time is that if you
you're going to be collaborating with
someone to do some type of project at
work you want someone who's really
paying attention of what's going around
going on in the environment around you
must maybe place in the broader sort of
seen the brother ecology the brother
space you also want someone who's going
to be really kind of looking out for you
and literally has her back again that
was definitely my experience with time
and this was someone that I could really
trust to have that environmental
awareness help sort of navigate and move
as a team through this way through space
in the process of media production that
was a collaborative process it had many
many people involved and
it was important because of the values
that you were there to stand up for
values that they are better
participation and investment and so on
and so forth from that time forward I
went on to collaborate or is a couple of
their projects and each time I had a
very similar experience this is somebody
who is a media artist who is incredibly
talented who works with some of the most
marginalized communities not to give
points to actually use processes of our
disciplinary design and collaboration to
to amplify attend and help build
community powered through VA arts
projects she's someone who always gives
credit to everybody in the process in
ways that are unfortunately getting too
rare and the type of hazards like ego
driven environments of both media as a
field and also cultural theory and
artistic practice so I would say you
know if you need someone who's gonna
have your back where instead that person
and if you want someone who's going to
be doing participatory community that
artistic production practices it means
that really really learn about
recognizing and lifting up the value
that everybody is bringing to the space
again
she is your person so with that I guess
that's all I have to say thank you so
much for being here were incredibly
honored
I graduated during the time when there's
an economic recession was just starting
which meant that I had the fortune of
being as there was very few jobs being
available to me with my art degree I
took on a number of jobs including that
all became important to me later so I
cared for someone in a wheelchair I did
woodworking and ran a woodworking
construction business for seven years
during that time we saw a lot of things
like well homie installed sheetrock the
sheetrock which is made out of this has
silly its silicon-based after we would
put up these walls and sand them down
then immediately the next day I would
get sick and be you know sick for a
couple of days and so I became aware
later of you know there's not enough
tightening of those health and safety
standards for for workers because it
would make the cost of construction and
real estate go up or for example one
time the wheel the saw on a table saw
came flying out and flew to the rafters
luckily did not hurt anybody but I was
just all really you know I became really
aware about the hazards on a workplace I
also worked as a advocate for street
vendors and also as a media advocate
with the organization that Sasha had
mentioned so these are some of the you
know the goals was to raise awareness in
the public in
evidence that could be used to end and
curb undemocratic things like illegal
surveillance and excessive force and
infiltration by the police and
infringement on the right to peacefully
assemble and the harassment of the press
so so my art background and the sundry
jobs led me to founding studio Rev which
is a non-profit and we Co design public
art and creative media with and for
low-wage workers immigrants youth and
women so some of the projects that we
created include we have done a number of
tools including this one called Kunta
sasha was a collaborator as well as
centro de los derechos Deming grande
which is an advocacy organization that
advocates on behalf of the 90,000 h2a
and h2b workers who come in from to come
and work and seasonal occupations here
in the US like crab harvesting or
working in fields the majority are from
Mexico and there's rampant abuse in the
workplace so this is a Yelp site where
workers can rank and rate their
employers it also functions then as a
job you know a tool for job seekers and
our role was in creating these audio
novellas as well as these comics this is
a project that is just about to come out
it is
do you guys know those maps that you get
on the subway you can unfold accordion
life like this they're called z-fold
maps so we have been working with the
mayor's office of immigrant Affairs on
these maps that use in English language
learner strategies to provide new
immigrants with resources about
immigration mental health services
participatory budgeting and more so
their distribution is through hundreds
of community centers and English
language learner communities throughout
New York City and we're using a language
of birds because vertical birds are
migratory so in that project and a lot
of the work they do this theme of
hospitality comes up and up because my
parents are immigrants I it's it's just
like kind of an incredible kind of an
incredible journey to get here and
establish oneself and so forth and the
theme of hospitality also figures into
this project which is a book that I
published about artists embedded in
government industries and electoral
cycles so the artists are using and
adopting the language patterns and
symbols of the larger institution in
which they're embedded in order to make
the work itself and actually I'll pass
it around along with the next one so
protagonist is a book that is about
productive friction and if antagonism is
about opposition allottee says Foucault
then agonism is about mutual incitement
and struggles so embracing struggle is
written in black and blue the colors of
a good bruise and it has a half-inch
hole in it actually if you have it can
you raise it up so you can see there's
an actual hole in it the idea about a
principle tentative agonism is that
about embracing the other so here the
half inch hole so you can frame the
other and keep them with you as you read
along so now I'll go into projects in a
more extended fashion among the many
jobs that I took when I graduated
undergrad was teaching chance in school
in public schools as well as after cool
school settings and my particular
interest was in teaching literacy
through art
and I had students that were that were
faced with these challenges so these
were the kids who came to my classroom
and this Howard Gardner's theory of
multiple intelligence appealed to me and
I thought was interesting or helped me
think through these different strategies
so according to the theory the you know
there's different kinds of intelligences
we tend to and especially in traditional
schools tend to emphasize the top two
mathematical logical and verbal
linguistic and a lot of kids that I were
coming in my classroom had other skills
and other strengths and so if I could
leverage those and they would get
excited about literacy so a friend of
mine in Honduras invited me to come to a
project on Honduras and she said you
have to come they have the largest
library there in northern Honduras and
so I went to go see this library and it
was a bookshelf long so my goal was to
encourage will spark people's excitement
about reading and encourage literacy so
here's the project that we did
[Music]
[Applause]
so um I should mention that that project
we I staged it with this community first
eight years ago and I didn't know at the
time that community which is up in the
hills may have very bad cellphone
reception and you'd have to come down
the hill and you know call someone on
your cell phone so we didn't have and
they didn't have very much email so I
didn't have regular communication with
them and a year and a half after we did
it I was talking with one of the
organizers and they casually said oh
it's people have been need a week and I
was like what's that she said oh you
know that it so she told me that they've
been carrying on its tradition and doing
these kind of serialized
episodic plays like skits and inventing
new characters and so forth um so I
think why that project worked or what is
sticky about it was that it's it's used
this strategy of white labeling which is
that you know it's easily adaptable
and it can take a life on its own
without me being there and so you know
in the United States the Seattle Public
Library adopted Beulah bandido as their
mascot for their digital media programs
and they do this annual teacher
librarian training to six to sixty
individuals who then adapt you look
India for the only so it's carrying on
without me
this is a recent exhibition in Central
Harlem where there's a 30% 30% of the
middle schoolers are below the standard
literacy rate and I think for me it's a
guiding project also and because it fits
into well Arabian Nights is for me a
guiding North Star and people began Dido
for me kind of fits this what this did
so Arabian Nights was developed over
many millennia by women
over several continents so it's this
collaborative an ongoing story frame
with the frame tale with different
stories tucked in between in another
project which is also a frame tale I
have been an artist in resident with the
National Domestic Workers Alliance for
the past eight years and for context for
this collaboration you may know that in
the 1930s and 40s is when most workers
receive basic rights like minimum wage
and days of rest and overtime wage but
domestic workers and farm workers were
excluded from receiving the same rights
because at the time they were largely
African American and southern lawmakers
would not include would not pass those
laws unless they were excluded and so
this legacy of you know of injustice
persisted until the 90s when domestic
workers started organizing telling their
stories to lawmakers in Albany and in
2010 passed the nation's first domestic
workers Bill of Rights and to get the
word out to the 200,000 domestic worker
so nannies housekeepers and caregivers
in New York we created this audio
novella app you call in three four seven
work 500 on any kind of phone this is
the time before smart phones were
accessible and you'd hear what sounds
like click and clack and Car Talk but
for nannies and when other states
started passing their Bill of Rights to
meet domestic workers where they're at
we created this mobile studio called the
nanny van and myself and my friend and
Jim and my newborn son would team up
with domestic worker advocacy groups
around the country and we've come to
unpack and we would do these sessions
where we would exchange information and
parlay what we had part so it's this
kind of fluid you know sharing of
resources and so forth and we would
create different kinds of things along
the way so we continue making these
audio novella apps
we sometimes made these paper toolkits
we call them so I spent a lot of time
reading through laws and thinking about
how they could be simplified or made
funny even or accessible I was doing a
lot of recordings and interviews and I
produced four songs that feature the
songs of domestic workers which are
featured in the film that you'll hear
Charlie and we also started
choreographing these dances so the
dances a lot of the domestic workers
that we were working with particularly
Filipina or Latina women were really
familiar with like kind of group and
line dancing and so we then started
using that as a medium to fold in
information and convey history of rights
and also as a way to prompt them to
share what they knew so the movements
essentially kind of encode this
information and there's a lot of fun and
you know people learn it because there's
laughing and then we also started
playing with graphics this is something
I produced that has been in a few museum
spaces and using social media and at the
time when my son was born I started
reflecting on what are the best and most
impactful ways that we were reaching
people this is our audience engagement
plan in which I'm you know we sat down
with my collaborators and we charted out
okay well this piece of media is used
for this appeals to this demographic and
you know a lot of the workers are using
Facebook for this thing but not but not
for this kind of information so this is
a way to both get on board with our
partners as well as figure out what is
lacking and so we started recognizing
the role of I mean despite I previously
had like sculptures and installations
and museums but um I I then started
recognizing that it's domestic employers
you know like myself who spend time in
museums you kind of have this captive
audience so I used the language of WPA
era posters which is also the same
moment when workers were excluded from
receiving the same rights and I made
these silkscreen
prints and I was using you know these
WPA poster strategies of being
explicitly didactic and conveying walky
things that I wanted people to be angry
change or inspired by so and then
further to in order to appeal to
domestic employers we created this film
which is twenty four minutes long and it
comes in four parts for Pete that went
on PBS digital and this is the first
episode
[Music]
like most working parents and still
figuring out this is Anjali my
collaboration with making our three
years son would be a jumbo before she
caught the gentlemen
she still does we have your parents from
seventies we live across the country and
don't have a safety net
everyone financial means support them
where that elected the most recent
project is with domestic workers and
advocates like Asian food
[Music]
our collaboration led to the project
with Falk Air Force but movement that
celebrates domestic workers and the
people in here
[Music]
this is an award organizer in New York
City Health fascinations first was a
domestic workers basic workplace
protections and this way
[Music]
[Applause]
one was a huge hit that's not amazing
more exciting well first of all I guess
love three other care works are there in
Miami
[Music]
the world
core issues in carriages
[Music]
and find solutions to both when they
basic people we meet along the way next
up we travel to DC to meet a caregiver
who's fight injustice um so this
question of success comes up like how do
you define that and what are your goals
and on the one hand we know things like
1200 people called in per month on the
audio novella app without you know in
the first few years without any
advertising except for word-of-mouth we
know that we with the project all
together we were you know we got media
coverage it should be said that I felt
that whenever the whenever our work was
in the news the thing I didn't care if
they got they included my name I don't
care if they got the project
interpreted incorrectly what the goal
that we established with our partners
was as long as they used the word
domestic worker or domestic employee it
was doing the work that we wanted to do
so that was a win for us
we also yeah we presented it also in a
number of you know like the Department
of Labor who asked us the kinds of
workers that you reach are ones that are
you know they're not counted in the
official workforce and so we do actually
don't know how to reach them so that was
important we know that for example we've
we recognized that it's like it wasn't
so much the eyeballs on the video itself
that we're doing impact work is like
when I was doing screenings and also
when there's social media around it that
was doing the work that we wanted to do
with this project so we did a tweet chat
which
we were surprised to find it trending
just below Janice and Justice Kennedy on
June 27th so on a personal level there's
a number of people who would tell me you
know I never identified as a nanny and
I've been doing this work for 15 years
until I walked by the nanny van or until
I encountered this project so people yes
so or like domestic employers who would
say you know I'm thinking of an
individual who is works on a museum it's
super conscientious individual his
daughter is in a wheelchair and he is
family has relied on caretakers you know
I just haven't thought about the history
of caretakers or thought about my role
as domestic employer until I saw this
work so and then there's this cake thing
here we were on Facebook as one of the
domestic worker groups in California
that we had worked with around an Anna
van event we really after the event
found this picture of a cake that was
made in the shape of an animal it was
orange and it wasn't that they asked us
what was what which was fantastic in
other words they felt so enfranchised it
was such a positive experience for them
that they wanted to make a cake on the
occasion of its one-year anniversary so
that was that was an honor okay so now
I'm changing powerpoints
okay this is a new project our student
for many years was next to this NGO
called peripheral vision International
and they do work in Honduras and they
have an office as well in Brooklyn and
at the time they were telling me about
the work that they did what which is
media advocacy and Human Rights and they
would do these video PSAs so it might be
a two minute video about how something
like Zika or you know random public
health service announcements that was
important to them and they would take a
commercially pirated DVD and they would
burn their video onto the fore part of
the DVD so it plays before you see
Terminator 2 it for example okay and
they would these really go out and they
would be sold and distributed through
these video halls sold on the street and
in these video halls
where people gather together and they
watch multiple screens at once the
majority of videos that come in are from
Hollywood in Hollywood or Bollywood and
this anyways going to it in the video
and this is what the outside looks like
and the context to this project that
I'll share with you shortly is that in
Uganda the things that they were there's
significant human rights concerns so as
in for example a friend of ours who
produces play with the game man
was thrown into jail so alternative
perspectives were really key and the art
to play a really important role in
discussing things that you can't
normally discuss so in coding things
they asked me to they said you know most
of stuff that
comes in is commercially you know these
commercial flicks there's no alternative
perspectives would you curate something
that presents we want to know what
alternative film and video looks like in
the West and there's a burgeoning
community here and there they were part
of this conversation as well and we want
to know what that looks like so this is
the project that we that I curated which
features seven artists from
[Music]
so then my collaborators and you gotta
asked me well we wanted to make
something anew and in reflecting on my
relationship with Uganda which is kind
of you know incidental via this
automated office made of mine at the
time I noticed that on a lot of the
video halls there was these pictures of
Bruce Lee which I thought was curious
and there's just like a general
enthusiasm about Bruce Lee and I was
thinking about when I grew up in Dallas
Texas and I felt so invigorated when
Bruce Lee was on my television I like
Chinese Ecuadorian kid in Dallas Texas
he felt I felt like he was my personal
ambassador and so I started watching
these Bruce Lee films again and I kept
on thinking about this scene and Enter
the Dragon do you guys know the scene
raise your hand a few knows it okay so
Bruce Lee is getting busted up and he
can't see his enemy because he's in
solver ears and he remembers his sensei
who says to him to defeat to vanquish
the enemy you must kill the illusion and
so I was like what does that mean how do
I interpret that allegory about mirrors
and looking at truth and deception so
forth and I started thinking about how
for me I understand truth through
another individual and so I would say
you know I felt like I would I wanted to
make a project in which the other person
there was this process of looking and
through this other person you know
through another and I started by making
these masks
snacks
where you see yourself reflected from
the other and also distorted and mirrors
are one of the things that have always
been an inspiration to artists from
Rembrandt to Velazquez to Van Eyck to
mural you please this is a sanitation
truck where you see yourself implicated
and what you're throwing out and so I
kept on to New York making these
vignettes with my collaborators and I
realized that it was such an interesting
way to explore things that we would
otherwise never talk about or interact
around and it was this way to explore
these other states of affect and it
would kind of draw out people's new
narratives or we felt like you're
forging new MS and it felt like an event
so yeah it encapsulated this idea of
what Victor Turner calls big twist in
between and also this idea that the
Liberatore nature of masks by the virtue
that they conceal so I'm going to share
with you this video that's a work in
progress that I I created with my
collaborators in Uganda
[Applause]
[Music]
so in these vignettes were exploring
myths and rituals and we thought of this
scene as you know there's many cultures
around the world where there's a
character who is ferrying or boding
someone from one side to another I'm in
occupying this liminal space and I then
have taken that project to other places
as in over this past summer I went with
his family a friend of mine who's from
Kazakhstan she invited me to go on this
family vacation with her and her two
daughters and she I said you know I have
to work on this I have to working this
deadline I got this this show at this
museum and Utah and she said just bring
it along we'll just do it with you I was
like okay so I went on this family
vacation and here we are this is one of
the teenage daughters yerkey and we're
kind of exploring the history here we
are at who's becca stan and we were this
the vignette was prompted by this this
kind of bridal Hat and so we were coming
up with a story about these characters
and people can kind of get wrapped and
fold it into the thing and volunteer to
be part you know show us and take us new
places this is the tour guide who got
really excited about being in them and
then she took us to his favorite place
which is this lake and
we next went to ossify Jean they were
visiting a friend of mutual colleague
and you know other by Jean is a place
where there's also human rights issues
and people you know this is my friend
Faye you got met who's an artist who is
also very aware of the role that he
plays in coding information through the
arts and it's a way to speak out in the
midst of censorship this is not for each
of us as well he's not betraying us
full-time this is an individual who
wanted to be in this vignette but
couldn't we he didn't want his name to
be associated with it because
professionally he might be compromised
if he was shown wearing a shirt we
thought of this vignette as the breakup
so here they are these pieces in a
museum right now interventive both
there's some in a kind of gallery
setting and then there's some that are
kind of interventive like the one about
death that with the driver
she's interventive in this hall with
mummies there's this they're demons or
ghosts okay so the last project I'm
going to share with you and end with is
well I'm gonna start it and you'll see
sorry can we bump up
[Music]
whoa popular music
okay so there's a team of scientists in
Florida who are trying to harness the
energy from lightning
they sent a rocket outfitted with the
copper notes into the air and under the
right atmospheric conditions copper ions
induce a lightning storm the energy
travels down to the ground via a coil of
copper wire
[Music]
we have to wonder if me and my IUD
outfitted with its highly conductive
copper we were standing near that rocket
do you think I would fail tingle in my
cooch and I started to wonder about the
way that copper suture is the natural
and built environment coursing through
our bodies poems and motherboards mining
copper is seen by some as a relatively
harmless extraction process a necessary
evil even enabling ecological solutions
and I started wondering about who is
doing this earth moving a copper was
first mined in 8000 BCE on the island of
Cyprus home of Venus of Aphrodite which
is how they share the same alchemical
symbol that was later taken up by the
women's liberation movement copper has
been used in contraceptive devices for
millennia most recently was used in the
IUD starting in the late 60s
contraception advocates like Margaret
Sanger saw the IUD is a tool to liberate
women and encourage pleasure but by the
60s and 70s corporation's population
control advocates and NGOs position the
IUD as an essential sterilization device
that could control America's low-income
indigenous and immigrant communities and
solve the quote population bomb of the
global south millions of women were
given the IUD without their consent or
economically incentivized to accept the
IUD but many of these women especially
in patriarchal societies where they felt
it wasn't safe and safe to openly
challenge their husband saw the IUD as
an invisible long-term contraception
device that gave them the ability to
control their bodies and lives
problematically one of the IUDs used by
two point five million women was the
plastic gun shield
anybody can remember that coming up
released on the market in 1971 without
adequate
testing the devices multifilament string
carried bacteria from the vagina into
the uterus which led to an increased
likelihood of infections septic
abortions and infertility 818 women died
200 thousand reported serious injuries
and after 12,000 lawsuits and mass
upwards that Dalkon shield was finally
pulled off the market in the late 80s
while after an pharmaceutical company
went bankrupt
since that time scientific advances
improved the safety of the IUD and in
the early 2000s after memories of the
Dalkon shield faded the copper IUD was
reintroduced to moms in the global north
like me as a means of family planning
which brings us to today so a week after
Trump was elected Planned Parenthood saw
a 900 percent rise in women requesting
the IUDs a contraception that outlast
Trump's presidency uncertainty in
Supreme Court's also drove up the number
of IUD numbers as did the Supreme Court
confirmation of Kavanagh while
anti-choice conservatives attempt to
rewrite science and scientists push back
advocacy organizations are doubling down
on campaigns that affirm the right to
you to choose and repr justice
organizations continue to focus on the
way that women of color have
traditionally faced economic and
systemic barriers and gaining access to
contraceptive technology so against the
complex history of the IUD and its
bright future the IUD for many of us
today is a tool enabling
self-determination and desire it's an
antenna connecting me with 170 million
women across the world who also have
copper antennae and I want to create a
monument commemorating our collective
bio power I want to solder my ID to a
lightning rod that sits atop a very top
building besting it by an inch imagine
as the bolt of lightning strikes the IUD
radiating into the atmosphere a tingle
resounding in the name of Reaper justice
technological self-determination and
women's desire so this is just the start
of the project as I'm working on a book
and a film and public art components
I'll also be revealing them are engaging
people in social media and with that we
have respondents
[Applause]
I hope there was news today that
logically
and so as those kind of choices have to
be really carefully made and rigorous
and really tested you know why a film
laying out why a road trip when the
experimental film it has to be a reason
that you use the tools not just because
if we use everything you get people
engage and they're really lights out the
integrity of form and media and it
create anything or any unknown questions
or reflections instead
and its identity they think it's artists
we are always going towards attention
we're going towards the questions the
reality that doesn't exist that we're
hoping to create into reality kinds of
things
and so I really feel like the both rule
and towards of these attentions and I
think what worked like an apology I was
actually the students today and
in ecology it depends on reciprocal
relationships and that's between any of
them so it's not just people right now I
need oxygen but only to choose between
oxygen without water next
there's an equity between the
relationship not inequality it's really
about each element being necessary
irreplaceable and different and the idea
of expanding the difference and that
really comes through the work that you
do different approaches and cultures in
different ways
it also speaks a lot
that you don't often use and how they
weaken systems don't think the American
piece of lace and understand what not
so some of the questions that I was
thinking
but I wonder how you define expectations
of the medium that has a long history
life
like for Orchestra and really
understanding your why don't you see
those things and so for me it really
makes you tricked a lot about your space
and how I would simply use a framework
near space maybe the space in which
appropriate appropriates certain aspects
of the material insertion world in which
we all live and composes them into
pounder instructions to create the
freeter space of expression resistance
space to be the other also to be
yourself under only turn roots and lest
economy and the less regulated your
space is useful and agreement of
assessing political and cultural change
in
both by what it's changed and what needs
to be changed and we become through that
process so it's really about
past present and future where it come
from who we are and not though only
those of us who identify as clear but
also part of a place making practice
that describes a new understanding of
space enabling the reduction of we're
comfortable publics that that often be
integrated spaces
for me I'm always engaging in the
construction investigating that communal
space in existence and they think Marisa
is also you're also working to create
spaces that
that not winter so even though the
restive workers might only lost all the
buying themselves to domestic workers
through your road trip they may define
themselves as part of an enemy which is
yet another community and engagement a
lot of really risky work to do that can
create communities that don't exist it's
really kind of exploiting in the best
sense of the word
the idea being part of the tribe
remember try and be
well that happens interracial children
prey it happens
idea that we see ourselves
some that exist and some that don't and
Larissa really allows these kind of
revelations and view and really tripped
up platforms it is the invisible as a
tool a political state and aesthetic
that I think
boys in trading books that are under
stolen and inviting people to and she
said sacrifice for pleasure or joy
sacrificed as a pleasure
whether she sneaks inside a well-oiled
media rogues room in Nevada and actually
spend a lot of time in Uganda and it's
really like this work it rolled on top
of Roman collar bone needs experiential
meets experimental and it's really a
very interesting thing that she is able
to actually
led operation and surprised them by
injecting experimental videos it's
really about the life of the seen and
the unseen by the scene in the unseen
and what it really does is add oxygen
and
to experiences and narratives we think
we right now I'm just using the last
word my UD periodic table top tarnished
climate self-determination electrical
field
right and let's not forget sex and we
don't need in Mundi if you're not having
sex with the options that we could
possibly get pregnant so one thing that
I just want to end
we work and something he did bring out
is and a question that I engage love -
is it socially engaged or something
impactful work comes up that there are
no best practices how do you understand
best practices and are there techniques
and practices that everyone should be
using and helping the idea of the best
practice actually relate to social
innovation art when in fact the practice
actually is reflecting a forest
relationship and nature a necessity to
society and how it's changing and so
many best practices work at one time
one situation with one partnership with
medium and one another and is it
actually acceptable in our team
do practices is there a right way to
allow art-making
in autonomy kind of freedom and
to exist and search out what it needs to
be while also understanding the best
practices in order the best way is to do
work that's impactful and also engage
participants how do you create tools
that challenge assumptions in society
and also or gemacht and assess society
in those systems I think that I would
just like to
[Music]
we're encouraged to employ genres in
three and almost relentless games and
really crossing social borders race
class and gender
you're right his partner would part
Museum in our cultural critique dark
garage our old history our penis between
even more and you also play with
experience you unexpected and
[Applause]
and it's it's especially unusual because
this is not explicitly a series on
education but I come I have has
indicated a background that is both in
the arts but also because I realized
you're back
very early on in my growth of
development as an artist that there were
things that
I was trying to do in theater without
teacher I couldn't find another way to
get the insects without teacher and that
has that was a long time ago and it's
kept me going for the last 40 years I
just wonder how many people here
identify as teachers
[Music]
I don't hear very well
hearing aids but I can't Lourdes me in
the cab-horse video there's a early one
you identify yourself
I thought your hardest so I thought we
did but then I got worried that you
didn't I just made about because it's my
part what and you do and you don't
understand what people are saying so so
so there's a lot of teachers here and
how many other students in a sense
I appreciate your phrase about artists
go imported which I feel is also what we
should be doing teaching learning that
is for answers
questions in part and art serves as a
kind of people reading process and I
think teaching and learning also service
that is theirs they're very small
similar dimensions very strong aesthetic
energy in our universe one social
dimension
[Music]
obviously a strong intellectual school
you cannot simply purchase
from a learning perspective i think
[Music]
about the general engagement so so in
any hug more more in the last couple of
years about socially engage appearances
participatory practices I've been
thinking about it those practices a
learning lemons and things that seems
almost too obvious to stay
incredibly important mistake is that
there's no learning with in other words
learning is not so easy you can learn
some easy things fairly easy but the
hard things to learn and they take
sustaining the pager and anybody who's
ever told you that you've got your works
but I think it's the first three three
minutes first invincible border students
to make a decision that they once again
want to engage
to pay attention so that they begin to
become not just present but fully
engaged so whether I three my intention
as an artist as learning intentions
I still have that how to get and pulled
and to deepen that intention as keeps on
the page so that they so in a sense I'm
doing less less Thor and part of what I
think you know if we were to go back and
just play
this is approaches to gravity and I'm
just grabbing attention holding
attention and encourage you to first of
all American controversy to me
our almost cream is truly super first
journey and there's
[Music]
nice ones you just wouldn't think okay
what I want to do is scary should
applicants so that I'll get their
stories but there's so much playfulness
and in this idea of terrorize and so
much joy and what you need
as the kind of energy that yielded a
source this is from in parts of
literacies back if you just go back into
much more traditional sense not to miss
this is to get young people with all
this interview to get down into these I
think that learning perspective is
success and that's being the question
for me because every every every
I'm teaching I have the exact same did
this work did we get some are people in
a different place than they started do
they understand things that they didn't
before convey but can they engage with
the world in a different way in the
story
socially engage where it is the
interaction there is with people that
the work has to happen it's not just a
question of creating objects it's about
creating experiences and the question is
about documentation
and and the question is in document
so in a lot of these we receive what
getting of the quick version obviously
all of these could get hold of death but
we got less was a sense of what was
actually like to be there as a child to
be here
as a domestic to be there in any of
these contexts that you feel and and and
to engage in the meaning that experience
and I think that one of the challenges
for many of us as educators in order to
answer this question for assault about
success that is the meaning of this is
to figure out ways
[Applause]
so maybe I'll respond first to those
questions and then take other questions
um but so the question one of her
questions was about the something not
being a logical solution to how to get
kids excited about literacy and I'll say
that um what seemed to me was I was
thinking about Santa Claus and even when
you by the way people Bendita it's
bigger than Santa Claus in that part of
northern Honduras but there's a delight
in pretending as if you believe in Santa
Claus even when you don't believe and
there's it to lighten pretending what
you do and if you think about when
you're around a campfire as a kid it's
fun to pretend like you believe in
ghosts and you're getting scared so it's
what some people call the magical as if
and the other point and it also answers
in part my mother was a Berlitz teacher
for a short period of time do you guys
know what Berlitz is language
acquisition ladies language shakes and
the strategy of Berlitz that she you
know she would use it with me in the
household where they come up with these
really absurd associations and like
these very visual associations so
oftentimes I mean it's employ and
impacted my work because I'm trying to
come up with something that's so wacky
that you can't get it out of your head
and it also makes me recall the
conversation I had with the director of
the care for film when he you know we
were scripting it out the scripted we
were he asked me to describe how he came
up with
the care for so it just gives me s when
the film and it seemed to me actually
quite logical so part of its maybe being
I don't know we were it seemed logical
to me that that's how you would go and
meet people in another place and what I
would do with my child and then let's
see to your questions your questions are
about ecology queer space and best
practices so those practices I think
[Music]
user testing which is not really a
strategy that you learn in art school
it's something that you learn maybe
comparative Media Studies or a media
production or in film or like technology
or an architecture like any other thing
I I really don't understand I mean maybe
I'm like crits you know a couple of
grits and then you like put it out in
the world which scene seems crazy to me
but I mean I'm I'm interested in a scale
and the scale might be invisible to some
people but in order to make something
work I need to get feedback from a lot
of people and necessarily I also need to
involve you know the people who it's I'm
seeking to be in dialogue with I need to
involve them from the get-go in the
project itself so I think the co.design
like it's like dating you don't want to
get married you know right off the bat
you know you want to go for coffee and
then you want to get to know them and
see how they write or what their texts
are like and so forth and so you kind of
get to know and I might do I oftentimes
I'm doing kind of short projects to get
to know what that relationship is like
as in its common that you an advocacy
organization or like I'll work with
lawyers and they really don't know what
to do with an artist or what that even
looks like and so oftentimes the first
thing they think of is can you design a
flyer and there a lot of artists will
say no I mean this is beyond me but I
feel like I mean I happen to have I
taught myself graphic
I enjoy doing it he's really easy for me
to do that and it's a service and it's
just a way to start the conversation
it's like can I borrow you know a
spoonful of sugar from your name I kind
of think it starts out whatever so it's
like a I'm happy for it to start off in
transactions and um John Seely Brown who
is at Microsoft and he started off in
education he wrote this business manual
in the 90s when the US was starting to
offshore some of their labor and the
book this book is about managing those
relationships and there's a whole
chapter on what calls productive
friction and he also talks about in
collaboration in a way that that was
useful for artists working with our
disciplines or sectors and he describes
that there's three levels of
collaboration and the first one is
transactional levels and then it kind of
moves up to being integrated in which
you're sharing staff and resources so I
think it's helpful to students or you
know people who are wanting to engage in
these kind of practices to understand
that it's you kind of like to start it's
a sequence you know in culminate
other questions yeah
oh that was in the boom and you know
like the typewriters I mean I had a
cardboard like wife typewriter
well we so with the kids in New York
City around
neelaveni toe we the New York City
workshop was we were doing literacy 21st
century literacy so they were learning
we were teaching them the software
called popcorn Jas which Mozilla was
putting forward and we partnered with
them on that project and the theme was
people bandido and so we also like
filmed an episode of people Vindi to
ourselves and kind of wrote the script
to come up with like the costumes and so
forth and we decided that we needed a
bunch of kids who were these kind of
Scouts who we're trying to lure be able
to be neato - coming - they got home so
that's what we made cardboard
in
[Music]
that's a really good question really my
partnerships end up being multi-year as
in like a I mean I think I'm working on
three different things that are
developing over it's in for the past
decade and they start from kind of
transactional or you know like just kind
of slow dating space and then we check
in afterwards and we kind of see where
things are at and sometimes things come
up and so with the video sync Uganda
there's another group recently who was
like oh that's great you want to do this
linking to like okay well here's what we
learned so did I answer your question
oh okay I feel like that's a good in
terms of best practices that falls into
that question too I very carefully
choose the organizations that I seek to
partner with the criteria one of them is
that I look for groups on the ground who
are poised to achieve victory and
victory can be however they define it so
they're on the ground like I work with
an NGO in Honduras who's already doing
multiple programs there in Uganda it's
as NGO pluses community of artists and
filmmakers there and so forth and we
kind of decide and what that phasing is
like and sometimes something comes out
and were like oh that was unexpected
what if it we now do this so yeah
oh yes thank you um well I look for
organizations that have the where it's
one person one person who can then
parlay communication from a wider
network as in National Domestic Workers
Alliance is in the lines of ten thousand
women with chapters forty six chapters
and something like twenty three states
all across the United States I work on a
national level I check in with like one
person on a national level or sometimes
if sometimes working people one person
on like a regional level different
states local level City level or a level
but I need to be in contact with one
person as opposed to if I'm in
conversation with six people and then it
is like genetic open kitchen but so like
there's a funnel I also look for
organizations where they have the
creative capacity to engage in the
collaboration which is not always the
case as in creative capacity might be
they're too busy like Trump Bob elected
and that love the groups I was working
with like we were just putting out fires
we don't have time to do something
that's like outside of getting up by our
example it also is our I also look for
individuals who need I have identified
already that they need creativity to
solve something that they're seeking to
tap so I don't go in assuming I'm gonna
convince someone I'm looking for people
who are already wanting that and then I
look for organizations that to kind of
get humor or I mean people been do you
know there's like an edge there do you
know what I mean so if they don't that's
what I feel like I can bring to the
world
oh that's a that's a good question so in
usually in the art world there's the
individual author and then the other
people like don't get credited in ways I
think are actually important too
I use the theater model of authorship in
which there's the original script er may
or may not be involved with the
adaptation of the thing onto the stage
and there's the lighting person who gets
credit and there's the costume designer
who gets credited and then the iteration
of or you know how it gets deployed
depends on the energy from the audience
and what's working so that's how I think
of authorship I feel like when something
goes out in the world and goes beyond my
being there then I feel like it's a
success and I feel like it's also tapped
on a different level it's tapped into
this there's something for me there
that's in this idea of a death Drive and
also a transcendence I mean it's like
the IUD on the building being atomized
into this distending but yeah or like
millions of people abandon ethos like
this that to me that would be a dream
country
thank you
[Applause]